انا في سنه 2020 حوالي
سنه زي النهارده تقريبا من من سنتين كنت
عملت حادثه كنت نازل جنب البيت انا ساكن
في القاهره في الشيخ زايد كنت نازل جنب
البيت قريب من البيت جدا وانا ماشي
بالعربيه عادي رايح مشوار طبيعي جدا
ماشي بالراحه ما كنتش بجري على خلاف
العاده
عملت حادثه كانت شويه صعبه فالحادثه دي
كسرت هنا مش باين حاجات هنا في وشي يعني
المهم بعيدا عن اللي حصل في الحادثه
وبعدين انا كويس يعني زي الفل ما فيش حاجه
واحد صاحبي في وسط الحادثه دي جاب لي
الكتاب ده
طبعا مش مناسب للحادثه خالص
ولكنه مناسب للحياه دهي امتي
كتاب الجميل ده العظيم ده اللي كتب وتودي
هنري يتكلم عنها فكره
ان الانسان بيبقى جواها حاجات كتيره قوي
حاجات كتيره قوي دي بيفضل حاطتها جواه
افكار مشاعر مشروعات قصص عايز يحكيها ما
بيحكيهاش تفضل الحاجه دي جواه
وبيموت بها فهو بيقول ايه في اول الكتاب
ده بيحكي عن حوار حصل بين شخصين بيقول له
انت عارف ايه اغنى مكان في العالم
فقال له ايه اغنى مكان في العالم قال له
ان اغنى مكان في العالم هو المقابر لان في
المقابر الناس ماتت بكل الحاجات اللي ما
قالوهاش والافكار اللي ما طلعوهاش كل حاجه
حلوه كانوا عايزين يعملوها ماتوا وراحت
معهم واتدفنوا بها تمام فهو كان شويه
بيزقني انا شخصيا ولا اديك عشت اهو يعني
فطلع الحاجه قدامي طبعا وانا صاحي
فدي كانت حاجه مهمه يعني بس الكلام حلو
كويس ان احنا نقول وطلع الحاجه اللي جواك
واعمل والكلام ده كله صح احنا ليه ما
بنعملش كده يعني انا النهارده اكتر هتكلم
على ليه احنا مش بنعمل كده
احنا ليه بنضيف بنموت بكل حاجه اول حاجه
كلمه دي انا حابب اقول الكلمه كلمه دي
كلمه
هامه جدا في
حياتنا اليوميه ترجمتها الحرفيه في علم
النفس
الهشاشه النفسيه فكره ان الانسان يكون هش
نفسيه والاسباب الرئيسيه اللي بتخلينا ما
نطلعش الحاجات اللي جوانا خوفنا ان احنا
نكون هاشين نفسيا انا خايف قوي الحاجات
البسيطه ان انا عندي فكره عايز اكتب بوست
مثلا حاجه بسيطه خالص مجرد ان انا ادوس
شير ده عند ناس موضوع كبير جدا انا برضو
بقى عندي الموضوع ده كتير يعني رغم ان انا
بكتب بس
المراجعه دي حاجه كويسه ولكن في الاخر انا
عايز ادوس شير
لان لما بدوش شير انا بعرض نفسي لهشاشه
نفسيه ان في ناس ممكن تتقبل رايي الناس
ممكن ما تتقبلوش حجم اعجاب الناس باللي
انا عملته ده او عدم اعجابهم به
وده بيوصلنا لحاجه في كل حياتنا لما يجي
مثلا انا في شغلانه معينه عايز اقدم عليها
فكره وانا بقدم على الشغلانه دي احتماليه
رفضي الفتره ما بين ما بيردوا عليا ما بين
ما انا عملت
ومعهم مع اي حد انا معاه انترفيو هي دي
الفتره اللي انا فيها هش نفسيه انا هش لان
لو رفضوني انا هزعل جدا هعمل ايه مقدبش
بعدين لما ما قدمش اقول ايه الحمد لله
ربنا سبحانه وتعالى شايل لي حاجه احسن
فانا عشان كده مش حقيقي دي كلها
الناس بتعملها نفسيا علشان تحس ان القدر
كان بيعمل شيء اخر علشان يساعدني
قد يكون في بعض الاحيان القدر بيعمل حاجه
وفي احيان كتيره بيبقى انا اللي مقدمتش بس
ليه لان انا حتى في علاقتنا الشخصيه ممكن
حد مثلا عايز يتقدم لحد فعايز يروح يقول
حاجه ده مثل اكبر موضوع مثلا فيها شاشه
اللي هو انا لو رحت قلت يعني ايه قال له
سالتها ورفضتني
في نفس زي الاغنيه كده بالزبط انا لما رحت
قلت طب ما انت ممكن ترفضني فلما هترفضني
انا هزعل قوي طب انا مش هقول طب انا مش
هقول
هتحسب مشاكل تانيه برضو عشان كده متنبي
ليه بتشا انا بعيد وبحبه لو حد شافني قبل
كده لاني بقعد كل شويه اقوله والا المشقه
وايه ساده الناس كلهم هل جودو يفطر
والاقدام قتاله لولا ان في مشقه كانوا كل
الناس بقوا ساده انما اللي بيخلي انسان
سيد وانسان غير سيد هو تحمله للمشقه واللي
هو جزء من المشقه الهشاشه النفسيه اللي
انا ببقى موجود فيها في الوقت اللي فيه
الشك ده اللي انا مش عارف النتيجه هتوديني
على فين فايه الجود يفطر ان الانسان لما
يبقى جواد بيساعد بيتحرك بيعمل حاجه ممكن
يفتقر والاقدام قتاله ان ممكن الشجاعه
تؤدي بانسان الى انه ايه يموت دي نقطه
مهمه جدا ومن الاسباب الرئيسيه اللي
بتخلينا ما نقدمش على
القرارات اللي فيها حاجات في حياتي
فان هي ممكن تحسن حياتنا ان احنا
في كتاب جميل جدا اسمه
بيتكلم على عندها في
فصل في الكتاب كبير بيقول في ايه
انكاردج جو تو جيفر ان الهشاشه النفسيه
والشجاعه يسيراني معا يعني كل الشجعان
اللي في الحياه هم هشيل نفسيا كل الناس كل
الناس اللي خدت قرارات في حياتها كبيره
بلا استثناء من اول الناس اللي غيرت
التاريخ مرورا بالانبياء مرورا بكل الناس
دي بيجي لهم وقت كده هم مش فاهمين طب احنا
احنا ايه الموقف دلوقتي
فبرحيم يبلغوا الناس بفكره برساله بدعوى
باي شيء الفتره ما بين تقبل الناس
لافكارهم دي وعدم تقبلهم هي الفتره اللي
بيكونوا فيها عشرين نفسيا جدا جدا
بس في نفس الوقت
اللي بياخد القرار انه يحط نفسه في فتره
الهشاشه دي هو الانسان الشجاع الحقيقي هي
دي الشجاعه الحقيقيه مش الشجاعه زي ما
احنا
بنتصورها في حياتنا العاديه ان الانسان
الشجاع ده يعني ما بيحصلوش حاجه من جواه
خالص لا بالعكس وهي بتحكي في الكتاب
بتتكلم على
القاده اللي هي قابلتهم في حياتها وبتتكلم
معنا اكتر القاده قسوه في قراراتهم يعني
بياخدوا قرارات صعبه زي مثلا في ظروف
اقتصاديه مثلا يحصل
تقليل عدد الموظفين اللي موجودين في حاجات
قرارات بقى اللي هي ايه هاخد قرار كبير
يعني هل هو من جواهم ما بيكونوا موضوع
بالنسبه لهم عادي يعني مش عاديين جدا جدا
وهم بياخدوا القرار بس هو مش باين عليه ان
انا يعني محدش بيطلع يقول انا كان عندي
هشاشه وانا باخد القرار المعين تمام فسب
الرئيس ان احنا بنموت بالحاجه وبنطلعهاش
فده اول حاجه
انا مش هطلع الحاجه ليه عشان انا عايز
حاجه تطلع مظبوطه ميه في الميه عارفين
لو في حد بقى هنا طبعا حقيقي هيبقى الكلام
ده بالنسبه له مناسب جدا انا هقعد اراجع
الحاجه من اليوم مره بس في الاخر برضو ليه
عشان هي مش مزبوطه ميه في الميه برغم من
الناس كتيره طلعت حاجات هتلاقي مثلا
يعني ايه دايما بنلاقي مثلا احسن اغنيه
اتشهرت لفلان الفلاني كان في ابنائي عشره
محدش سامعهم او بايزين اشهر مثلا الكتاب
بتاع باوله كله الشهير جدا ده برضو من
الكتب العظيمه وكتبوا سنه 1989
سنه 1989 لما كتبت شهر في اخر التسعينات
محدش اصلا كان بيسمع عن الكتاب
محدش بيشوف الحاجات دي كلها هو لو قعد
مخلي الكتاب عنده عمال يراجع فيه ويفصص
فيه ويفصص في كل معلومه مش هيطلع حاجه في
العلاقات اللي انا كنت بتكلم عليها
الموضوع ده مهم انا هقعد بقى استنى لحد ما
يبقى كل حاجه وبعدين ايه اروح اتكلم
ما فيش حاجه هتبقى بيرفكت بالمعنى ان انا
كل شيء بقى كل اركان المساله موجوده
فهنا برضو نقطه ان انا في درجه ما محتاجه
ان انا
استشير فيها اخرين ان انا اعرف هل انا كده
عند نقطه معينه اقدر اعلن الفكره دي اقدر
اتكلم عن التجربه دي اقدر اخد القرار
في مشكله مثلا
من قابلها في حياتنا كتير برضو من الكلمات
اللي انا حابب استخدمها النهارده بعد دي
اهم كلمه بكلمه تانيه دلوقتي في كلمه
هقولها في الاخر انديس
انديس في حياتنا بنقابل ناس انديس مش
بتكرره هم بيجمعوا معطيات معطيات معطيات
عن كل حاجه هنكرر امتى فسيح خلاص احنا
مواضيع باظت ورحنا في سكه صعبه جدا علشان
ما اتخذش القرار عكس انديس
يعني ايه
ان انا اعمل قرار سريع وفي نفس الوقت
القرار ده
فعال دي حاجه مهمه جدا وليها تبعاتك عشان
نفسيه ما اعرفش حد شاف فيلم كابتن سوني
لما اطار بالطياره للي ما شافش ممكن ابوظه
له شويه شويه فيلم جميل اتفرج عليه الخمس
سبعه مرات كابتن سوري ده طيار هي قصه
حقيقيه هيطلع بالطياره من جي اف كي من
مطار نيويورك وهو طاير هتحصل حاجه غريبه
جدا ما بتحصلش تقريبا في التاريخ الطيران
كله في طيور هتخش في محركات التيار
فالطياره هو هيسال برج المراقبه انزل فين
فبرج المراقبه هيقول له انزل في نيوجيرسي
انزل في مطار نيوجيرس نيوجيرسي سموه ده
بيدروم نيويورك زي كده دبي والشارقه
لازقين في بعض كده عشان ارخص فالناس بتروح
تبات هناك وتشتغل في نيويورك الصبح فقال
له انزل في نيوجيرسي او مطار فهو لقى من
خبرته من الزمن الطويل ان هو مش مفهوم مش
هيلحق ينزل في نيوجيرس بالطريقه دي فقرر
انه يعمل الهبوط فين
في النهر فهبط في النهر الطياره ما زالت
موجوده حتى الان محتفظين بها فيلم عظيم
يعني ممكن تتفرجوا عليه بس النقطه
الاساسيه اللي حصلت في الموضوع هو القرار
والقرار ده برضو خلاها ليه لانه حسب معه
تحقيق كبير جدا من سلامه النقل في امريكا
ان انت ايه اللي خلاك تهبط في ان تعرضت
حياه 155 راكب للخطر في نهايه التحقيق
تحقيق براوا كان دي اخر سنه له وبعدين طلع
على المعاش السنه اللي بعديها حياته وختمت
بشكل جيد يعني القرار لكن لما هتاخد
القرار
في تبعات مش لازم تكون تابعات حلوه انت
كنت تابعت فيها شويه صعوبه بس على المدى
البعيد في حاجات ممكن تتغير
فسيكينج تو بيرفكت حاجه التالته درايفن
باي نستنت
يعني هيك كلمه لطيفه دي
ان انا بعمل حاجات مش هو القرار اللي في
الاخر بس بعمل حاجات صغيره تانيه تحسسني
عن نفسي بالرضا بمعنى ايه مثلا انا بعت
النهارده ايميل انا عملت اللي عليا خلاص
كده انا دوست ما فيش الشعور بتاع ما بدوس
سند بحس انا كده تمام ليه انا بحس ان انا
تمام
عشان بتحصل فيه
هرمون السعاده ده بيديني حاجه ان انا كده
عملت اللي عليا ممكن اروح اعمل نشاط مع
ناس ممكن اجي احضر النهارده مثلا جميله
وشكرا يعني اكيد بس في حاجه تانيه انا
علشان هعمل الخطوات الصغيره دي خطوه
الصغيره دي بعملها علشان حاجه تاني
بنوت بالحاجات اللي جوانا والافكار اللي
جوانا والحاجات الكبيره لان احنا عملنا
حاجات صغيره تانيه تحسسات تحسسنا بالرضا
عن نفسنا بس هي مش الحاجه اللي احنا كنا
عايزين نعملها او الحاجه المفروض نطلعها
يعني مثلا ممكن يكون حد عايز يكتب كتاب
معين عن حاجه معين فكتب مقاله في المقاله
دي يعني
والناس قعدوا يشير وكده فانا احس ايه
بتلاقي حد مثلا عايش على مثلا بوست مثلا
بالحظ ضرب كده كل شويه اعمل له حطه كده
وكل شويه اتفرج عليه
لا دي كلها حاجات كويسه ما هياش حاجات
سيئه ولكن انا في حاجه في النهايه انا
عايز اوصل لها فالانستانت جرافيكيشنز دي
ما تخدعنيش في الحياه بالذات جوه الشغل
اللي من حضراتكم بيشتغل وبيتعملوا على
الايميلز كتير انا النهارده رديت على فلان
وعملت فلان وبعت كذا وبعثت كذا هل انا
شايف جوهر الموضوع الحاجه اللي انا كنت
عايز اعملها في الاول احيانا كتير في
الموضوع
رش دي بتعمل لي مشاكل كتير يعني نفسي
دايما اتكلم اكتر من رش لان هي خادعه جدا
تخدع الناس لان الحياه مش بتستمر بالانستا
انت مش بتستمر بتبقى مين رش من اللي
بتجيلنا من ان احنا قعدنا مع بعض في مكان
كويس عملنا حاجه كويسه تمام في جزء ثاني
متعلق بالتزامي الحاجه اللي انا بعمل بها
ان انا قاعد لازم اقعد مركز هتعب جدا عشان
اقدر اوصل للحاجه دي مش مجرد الخداع اللي
ممكن يحصل لي من الدوبامين
يعني ايه برضو ان لسه انا قدامي وقت
هعملها بقى
يعني بعد شويه فهو صديقي لما جاب لي
الكتاب يعني ما فيش وقت
لان هو في وقت في الحقيقه ما فيش وقت برضو
مش ان احنا نتوتر ولا احنا خلاص يعني لا
بس لازم دايما نبقى حاسين ان في حاجات
محتاجه مننا
ادراك للزمن ادراك للمرحله العمريه اللي
انا موجود فيها لما مثلا كان في التقديم
انا بحب الحاجات بتاعه السفر دي جدا ويعني
بشكل الحاجات الصعبه يعني تتحرك
بالمواصلات مثلا من وسافرت من القاهره كيب
تاون بالبر يعني
بمواصلات لحد ما وصلت جنوب افريقيا بس ما
الوقت بيعدي
الحاجه اللي انا كنت بعرف اعملها من سبع
سنين ممكن ما ابقاش قادر اعملها دلوقتي
لاسباب كتير اسباب اجتماعيه صحيه نفسيه
الحاجات دي بس في حاجات انا ممكن ما اقدرش
اعملها او بيبقى اصعب علي ان انا اقدر
اعملها في الوقت ده مش بقول مستحيل يعني
مش عايز حد ان هو خلاص والوقت ما اقصدش
كده برضو ما اقصد حاجه محدده جدا ان انا
احاول على قد ما اقدر الحاجه اللي ابقى
مدرك للمرحله اللي انا فيها ان الوقت ده
محتاج مني اتحرك في المرحله الزمنيه دي
بالتصرف ده ما اقعدش اؤجل الحاجه على اساس
ان الحياه لا تنتهي يعني العلماء بتوع
الفلسفه يقولوا القول بما لا يتناهى باطل
من الانفينيتي دي ان انا اقعد اقول لحام
لما ما فيش ميعاد دي حاجه ما ينفعش عقلا
ان هي تبقى موجوده
طيب الحاجه الاخيره انا عايز اختم بها
الكلمه دي دي الكلمه الثالثه انا قلت
يعني ايه مديوكريتي الكلمه دي اصلها لغوي
اصل اللاتيني بتاعها
جزئين
مادي يعني
جبل اكروس يعني جبل ميدياس اوكرس يعني في
نص الجبل
نسمع دائما يقولونك ده مديوكر ده فلان ده
ميديوكر عشان تسمعوا الكلمه دي لا ميديوكر
يعني
يعني مش يعني وحش ومش يعني حلو يعني
الكلمه حياه اللي هي النص نص دي انا في نص
الجبل انا طلعت الجبل وانا تحت في الارض
ولا انا انا في النص كده
جزء كبير من المشاكل اللي بتحصل في الحياه
لما بيكون المجتمع ناس كتيره من الناس
المحيطين بينا بديوك
خلاص بقى انا بالنسبه لي كلنا واقفين في
نص الجبل وكلنا كده ايه تمام ليه انا مش
عايز اطلع فوق الجبل عشان اربع حاجات اللي
فاتوا مش عايز اكمل الخطوه نفسيا عشان انا
خايف ان انا ابقى يمكن اطلع الجبل هينزلني
فمثلا ساعات ناس
بخاف انزل يعني ممكن اطلع في الحاجات بس
موضوعها صعب جدا حتى تصلح حاجه مثلا في
البيت فوق تيجي تنزل تحس الموضوع فيه
مشكله فانا خايف اطلع مش عارف انزل اطلع
ازاي
كل الحاجات اللي اتكلمنا عليها ان انا لا
انا عايز لما اطلع تبقى كل المعدات اللي
موجوده عشان اقدر اتسلق الحاجه دي كلها
موجوده في حياتي علشان اقدر اعمل حاجه زي
كده
فدي كلها حاجات مهمه الحاجه الاخيره لكوت
اللطيفه دي بتقول ان
ان دي مش بتحصل
بيننا وضحاها كده احنا نقوم من النوم
نلاقي ده حصل لا دي عمليه متراكمه بتبدا
من اول وانا طفل صغير في المدرسه كل
الظروف اللي انا بمر بها والبيت لحد الوضع
اللي انا فيه ده دلوقتي تبدا واحده واحده
تمشي بالراحه تروح الشغل
هي بتتعمل كده تروح الجامعه يقول لك هي
كده تمشي في الشارع وهي البلد كلها كده كل
ما نروح في حته يقول لك هو كده تمام يعني
ده
عموم الناس معظم الناس كده لو حد عايز ان
هو يطلع يتحرك سنه فلازم يبقى في شيء
مختلف عن اللي بقيه الناس بتعمله عشان ما
يبقاش ايه ما يبقاش فيديو يعني فبس يعني
في النهايه اللي انا عايز اقولها
اللي عنده حاجه مش بس بالكلام المحفز انك
طلعها وكده لا خلينا نعرف اسبابنا من
جوانا احنا ليه ما بنطلعش الحاجه دي من
جوانا ونبتدي ان احنا نطلع الحاجه ونعرض
نفسنا للعشاشه النفسيه دي وانا تقبلها
ونتقبل المشاكل اللي هتحصل لنا نفسيا كم
يوم وانا متضايق ان انا طلعت الحاجه
وبعدين ما نفعتش المره الجايه او اللي
بعديها هتنفع ومش هطلعها وهي لسه يا اما
طيور خالص لا انا هستشير حد برضو مش بقول
نجري كده كل واحد عنده حاجه دلوقتي يقولها
الموضوع يجوز ولكن يبقى عندي اقل قليل او
لحد الادنى اللي يخليني اطلع الحاجه دي من
جوايا ما افضلش شايلها واموت بيها في
النهايه ما ابقاش حد انتفع بها ولا انا
ولا غيري ولا اي حد وفي النهايه ان احنا
كلنا هنموت لحد هيفتكر الهشاشه وانا شكلي
وانا كنت فاشل ولا انا قلت لحد ورف وانا
قاعد كله في الاخر ايه مليارات اللي راحت
احنا هنروح زي المليارات اللي راحوا يعني
فانا شاكر جدا وساعدت بوجودك